déployé sur près de 19 hectares le foyer
albert barbeau est un lieu de soins et
de vie pour quelques 500 pensionnaires
enfants adultes et personnes âgées c'est
autour de lui que s'est développée
l'écart saint pierrois de bois d'olive
aujourd'hui c'est une véritable
institution
meetic se souvient d'albert barbeau
mais albert bargués
jeunes qui étaient très exemplaire et
très méritants et une 5 et aviateur lui
il est mort
tous les débuts de la guerre
albert barbeau net à saint-pierre le 26
juin 1919 papaye commerçants longtemps
même président de la chambre de commerce
maman est artiste et compose nouvelles
et poèmes au lycée le jeune albert
excellent littérature c'est aussi un
sportif aimant le tennis et par dessus
tout l'alpinisme seul ou avec ses
camarades il gravit tous les sommets
franchi toutes les ravines de son île
c'est d'ailleurs pendant l'ascension du
gros membres que l'écho d'un coup de
canon dans le cirque de cilaos laverty
du déclenchement de la guerre l'appel du
18 juin résonnent dans le coeur de
l'idéaliste jeune homme sous le pseudo
fada il lance un bulletin mensuel la
tribune catholique des jeunes dans
laquelle il conteste la politique locale
en novembre 1942 il s'engage pour
défendre son pays il intègre le régiment
d'infanterie de marine de saint denis et
part pour madagascar au sein du
bataillon de marche numéro 2 pour
combattre en afrique il embarque
clandestinement à tamatave avec son ami
albert de fontbrune ils sont si motivés
qu'ils seront incorporés au contingent
qui fait route sur dar es salaam il
traverse ensuite l'afrique du tanganyka
l'actuel tanzanie à l'algérie
débarqué à 7 le 20 janvier 1945 il
participe à la libération de royan trois
mois plus tard mais le 15 avril 1945 un
accrochage avec l'ennemi sur la route de
didonne tu 23 soldats français dont le
sergent-chef barbeau
il est cité à titre posthume à l'ordre
de l'armée titulaire de la croix de
guerre et de la médaille militaire le
jeune héros repose aujourd'hui au
cimetière de saint pierre